hallo mein name ist luca herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video von wir uns zwar meine damen und
herren wir spielen heute ein neues spiel
und zwar das spiel namens trap adventure
das ist ein abenteuer mit fallen viele
youtube haben diese spiele bereits
gespielt und ich habe mir bei dem
anschauen des videos einfach gedacht hey
so schwer kann dieses spiel eigentlich
gar nicht sein deswegen spielen wir das
ganze spiel jetzt einfach mal selbst
wir sind hier in dieser welt drinnen und
müssen zunächst einmal auf diesen alles
cool wir müssen zunächst einmal auf
diesem blog in der mitte spielen also ab
auf den blogger haben wir wenig
bescheuert in der tat hier in die mitte
springen genau da bin ich da also ich
bin ja auf dem block wurf das
einzelspringen jetzt
ihr kleinen denkt er dass ich es lustig
also ich springe hier rüber und jetzt
springe ich hier und jetzt bin ich eben
den zweiten dingen drin das heißt ich
gehe sie hier live die app hersteller
also ich bin ja jetzt einfach mal
zwischen her
game over genau so sah das bei den
anderen youtube videos die ich von
diesem spiel bereits gesehen habe
wirklich auch aus also die bahn auch
komplett am verzweifeln also da muss ich
wohl auf dieses wo soll ich hin dann
also ich stehe jetzt hier
ich weiß dass dort dort und dort so
stacheln rauskommen das heißt ich
versuche jetzt einfach mit anlauf
darüber zu springen und zwar einfach mal
dich springen einfach nicht reagiert ich
nehme wieder anlauf und jetzt springe
ich ein bisschen ach komm willst du mich
verarschen
also ich bin jetzt hier ich versuche
einfach mal hier so langsam kommen aber
ich glaube ich weiß jetzt wo ich lange
muss solche apps
die sind richtig krass süchtig machen
weil man die ganze zeit verkackt also
freundlich die jetzt hier runter und
dann so ok wo gehe ich jetzt hin wenn
ich jetzt hoch springen und dazwischen
gehen
das sind wieder so komische teile das
heißt ich jetzt einfach mal hier runter
genau jetzt mal hier lang springen jetzt
hier hoch um die ecke jetzt online
nein das ist nicht wahr also auch wenn
es gar nicht so rüber kommen weil ich
mich die ganze aufregung er mich fahren
ich hasse diese ich feiere apps einfach
übertrieben
bei dem man die ganze zeit von vorne
starten für die ganze zeit vom neue weil
es einfach einen übels ab weil man
richtig am arsch ist also jetzt hier
vorne um hier so drauf
wurde raus und so wo ich schwöre auf
mein leben das hier nochmal stachel
kommen ich springe ich jetzt einfach
[Musik]
aber wie gerade schon gesagt ich liebe
solche apps notfalls ich irgendwann mal
eine eigene app machen sollte und ich
habe bock mal eine eigene app zu machen
dann werde ich glaube ich auch so was in
der art machen was hart hart schwierig
ist also ich laufe level 4 die scheiße
hierbei ist halt dass man die ganze zeit
von vorne starten muss das heißt wenn
ich hier bin kann ich nur pausen
das ist halt dieser experte das heißt
wenn ich einmal sterbe starte ich von
vorne dementsprechend lerne ich sage ich
mal nur alter wie soll ich das denn
machen das ist halt so ein modus wenn
ich einmal sterbe starte ich von vorne
das dementsprechend kann ich nur lernen
wie die level aufgebaut sind in dem ich
immer wieder von vorne startete das
heißt zwischen den einzelnen katzen
liegen bei mir mal so zwei minuten bis
ich wieder zu der stelle komme es gibt
ja auch den doppelmord m ich würde sagen
die spielen einfach unable to connect
wie ach ich habe im flugmodus an schöne
werbung angucken um weiterspielen zu
können den anderen modus hat sich jemals
in app gründen sollte dahin spiel
rausbringen sollte wird es definitiv
keine werbung haben freunde
ich hasse werbung in apps aber wir
spielen immer den doppelmord freunde
das ist genau das gleiche level nur wir
haben jetzt in verschiedenen leben
das heißt ich strenge mich aber trotzdem
an damit ich nicht direkt die ganze zeit
meine leben verbraucher also ich gehe es
hier lang kann ich da komplett nun kann
ich nicht ich dachte gar nicht kann er
komplett hoch springen aber so tolle
beinmuskulatur als auch hier waren dann
sind wir jetzt hier level 4
die sache ist dass da wahrscheinlich
dann ja gleich mehr wie soll ich da lang
wie gib 10g heimweg oder irgendwas ich
verstehe es kein scheiß nicht springen
ok hahaha ich geh ich gehe im moment als
mal so wird er auf mich aufmerksam
aber ich weiß wie es geht also ich
springe so der wirt auf mich aufmerksam
ich bin hier hoch wie hier und jetzt
gehe ich hier und jetzt kann ich hier
wie soll ich das machen
also hier lang springt als köder dann
vielleicht auch korn junge hörer mäßig
hier lang springen hier leicht hoch
genauso jetzt hier runter und jetzt wie
soll ich denn da lang die rechnung
direkt noch eine werfen drei minuten
warten
drei minuten später freunde ich befinde
mich hier wieder in der app ich darf sie
das spielen
das heißt ich gehe hier an der seite
runter hier lange hier lange die ganzen
level hier käme ja mittlerweile auch
schon hier lang genau jetzt bin ich
happy ich bin hier der clip die sonne
kommt raus hat sich die runter da sind
unglaublich einig hey ich glaube ich
muss einfach schnell sein das heißt ich
gehe jetzt so so ganz ganz schnell und
bammel was ist das gewinnstreben der
scheißhaufen ich weiß nicht wie ich hier
vorne lang springen soll oder da
irgendwie sowieso alles geschafft das
heißt ich bin jetzt hier drauf oh mein
gott ich bin auf dem teil der lasten
like da wenn ich teil zweimal spielen
soll ja freudig verarscht wirklich nicht
es gibt von dieser entwicklung
[Musik]
das kann doch nicht so schwer sein luca
kommen hier alter kommen konzentriere
ich jetzt mal so hier sag ihr auch hier
ist es denn so schwer es gibt von dieser
app wirklichen zweiten teil also trap
adventure 2 heißt das ganze soll hier
rüber kam ganz langsam vortags meldet
die kaffeezeit auch wenn man einmal game
over war im stark war sie komplett
wieder von vorne das heißt nichts wir
gehen jetzt mal ganz bedacht an die
sache ran springen hier hochgenaue
lassen uns zeit gehen wow das ist echt
cool hier langsam rein gehen hier hoch
springen lassen wir uns jetzt mal
zeitgenau springen weil hier auf den
typen darauf genau
ganz langsam genau hier auf die mauer im
jetzt warten wir einfach mal ab freunde
genau das gemeint und etwa hier drauf
hätte hier auf den rand es kann doch
nicht so schwierig
mein gott mein letztes leben alter das
ist doch nicht vorkommen hier und jetzt
springen auf den hof wunder und rapper
und teppichreste noch nicht aus denn das
ist ja alles eigentlich gar nicht so
schwer dass es einfach im cupspiel das
kann doch nicht so wie geht's gut
wir sind wieder noch immer den level 5
ne klasse einfach springen wir hier auf
den das war mein portemonnaie scheiße
ist auch alles heile glückwunsch ich
denke hat die ganze zeit so daran dass
es einfach nur ein cupspiel ist das hat
irgendwer entwickelt und es muss alles
möglich sein also wird es muss möglich
sein dass man das irgendwie hinkriegt
also ich bringe hier drauf ich stand ja
schon auf den dingen bestand ja auch
schon auf ihr auch den komischen pfeiler
genau das hab ich eine chance hier
draufzukommen genauso das ist nicht wahr
so nah war ich doch kein mal dran freund
aber das motiviert mich jetzt natürlich
weiter zu machen also wie das jetzt
wirklich mal zeit ich spreche jetzt noch
nicht nur auf freunde sondern ich warte
jetzt springe jetzt hochgenaue springe
jetzt hier drauf jetzt jeder
ein letzter dran alter schwer
ich drücke auf schräge und er komme
nicht auf sein leben klar die auf dem
pfeiler freunde
wir haben mit zeit wir haben neun leben
und da ist als erster läufer wieder
langsam auf den feldern zu laufen hier
drauf gehen genau warten darauf den das
scheißhaufen genau da ist habe ich den
auf der karte stehen auf der karte und
jetzt ich würde gerne mit euch über
aggressions probleme reden ab auf den
pfeiler hier freunde wir warten wir
springen ganz leicht gehen nicht auf das
casting sondern wir konzentrieren uns
wieder auf den pfeil erwarten wieder
auch das kag den gehen drauf springen
hier auch hier haben alle zeit rein
leben freunde sind meine letzten drei
leben die ich mir für diese spiele
gedacht habe so drumherum
hier vorne nochmal lang hier ab auf den
pfeil erwarten war mal gehen wir hier
drauf gehen wir hier darauf genau ich
habe alle zeit der welt
letztes erleben luca konzentrieren ich
und mein gott das ist mein letztes leben
wir gehen ganz ganz langsam darauf zu
bestehen auf dem pfeiler manager und
herren da vorne kommt das casting
springen auf das rating kaufen gehen
darüber auch die säule wir sind auf der
anderen seite setzt
[Musik]
was ich glaube ich grund sei aber meine
app bald